non so se avete visto che nell'ultimo
periodo un po ad minchiam ha pubblicato
degli shorts dei tic toc insomma tanto è
la stessa cosa che il pubblico un po da
tutte le parti e volevo fare una sorta
di momenti epici e di tik tok io li
chiamo tik tok ma in realtà sono shorts
i top un po tutto volo appunto fare un
video che raccogliesse i migliori
contenuti short che ho fatto è quindi
ragazzi buona visione let's go
[Musica]
[Risate]
rimedio numero uno per le zanzare
signore
ha poi
però stare qua
ha doti di flessibilità serietà
concretezza impegno apertura mentale
capacità di motivare gli altri di
informatizzare i problemi guardi cosa so
fare inflessibilità
adesso mi riprendo
soldi
[Musica]
[Risate]
magari disegno
among us
[Musica]
secondo abbiamo duplicato
ritratto dell'avversario
[Musica]
porco demonio porco morto perché nel
1800 la gente moriva di infarto per
questo
mamma mia ragazzi mamma mia oh c'è pure
un accendino che non voleva accendere la
mannaia
[Musica]
io
non l'avevo visto non sapevo della sua
esistenza ed era meglio se non lo sapevo
non posso accedere al primo quella
betoniera del mio amico è lì da
stamattina
non posso accedere al frigo ma perché
permette a chiunque di entrare in casa
mia
[Musica]
all
ora
[Musica]
all
a
bra
[Musica]
ecco i ragazzi vi interrompo perché lo
so che vedete tutto questo spielberg
ismo nei miei source ma anche oggi c'è
il momento sponsor e le gite un free fp
nove sono le cuffie che sto utilizzando
nell'ultimo periodo e hanno il noise
reduction cosa vuol dire una serie di
show in questa tecnologia incredibile
che è praticamente ti permette di
isolarsi dal mondo esterno quindi se
qualcuno russa oro bene oppure se non
volete sentire i miei video un'altra
un'altra motivazione potrebbe essere
quello inoltre la cancellazione del
rumore non infastidisce i comfort delle
cuffie e ormai pure le reazioni ti tocco
le farò più queste praticamente hanno
anche l'iphone spazio processing che
sarebbe questa cosa che simulano le
casse l'audio delle casse quindi
simulando delle vere casse sia un audio
nitido e spaziale la custodia di
ricarica inoltre diventa un
trasmettitore wireless per tutti i
dispositivi audio senza bluetooth come
ad esempio i computer e varie console
tutto il resto è sempre con la costruita
di ricarica e questa è una cosa che per
me è magia e si collega la custodia la
corrente con le cuffiette dentro si
attiva la tecnologia ruminano che
elimina i batteri il 99 della 9 per
cento di batteri non so che fine faccia
lo 0,1 mai capito e anche con full
carica durano dieci ore più o meno di
utilizzo se si aggiunge anche la
capacità di batteria del della custodia
si aggiungono altre 14 ore perché la
batteria della custodia dei di circa 14
ore che sommata quelli di prima sono
circa 24 ore quindi potete rivedere
tutti i miei tik tok più volte senza
ricaricare la batteria i ragazzi ha
detto questo bisogna tornare alla
compilation vamonos
[Musica]
a un foglio
la
natura
ciao benvenuto sul nostro sito di
incontri si guarda non me ne parlare
come la tua ragazza ideale ma direi
capelli lunghi ok alta ok magari non
fake beh questo non ve lo posso
assicurare ma ok fino adesso che
risultati abbiamo un goblin chirac
freddy krueger è una tartaruga
grossa ma se vuoi scoprire altri profili
sono 16 euro e 99 al mese
no guarda non interessano per avere il
nostro silenzio sul fatto che fa
vincesse iscritto al nostro sito di
incontri sono altri 25 euro al mese ma
come vogliamo fare 50 ok va bene fammi
vedere altri profili grazie per il tuo
pagamento oddio selena gomez e ti ho
ammazzato selena gomez sta per suonare
alla porta
buona fortuna
ciao baby
[Musica]
fratello
stavolta
[Musica]
sono
inter sono così tanti che sono convinti
che tutti quanti insieme potrebbero
distruggere un intero pianeta ma sapete
cosa
potete sempre decidere quanto peso dare
alle parole di vita se volete consiglio
non dategli in alcuno però dobbiamo
trovare un tatuaggio questo è bello m
solamente che lo trovo però sto
tatuaggio ma mica fighissimo
sisma house
tesi su satana is my friends è quindi
ragazzi questa è la compilation di tik
tok vi dico la verità fare contenuti
short molto molto molto carino nel senso
che mi diverte alle volte delle idee la
poi quindi si possono fare con amici e
cose così quindi mi sono divertito un
sacco oramai avete capito che da tempo
che faccio quello che mi piace 1
spiegato già un sacco di volte quindi
non sto a ripeterlo quindi sicuramente
in futuro farò contenuti anche un po più
corti magari anche qui su youtube però
andavano assolutamente presi tutti e
archiviati sul canale perché secondo me
e messi insieme
secondo me questo vizio della madonna
però mi spingevo elogiare da socia siamo
grati a questo punto ragazzi veramente
ma che fine ha fatto quindi ragazzi
spero che questo vi sia piaciuto
è un mi piace anche marito che quindi
trascrizione se ne sono resi schiavi e
noi come sempre ci dividiamo adozione e
ragazzi
[Musica]